Sorgt direkt, mal am anfang es geht
Um den saturnmond titan der ist nämlich
Spektakulär wie sich immer mehr heraus stellt der saturnmond ist in vielerlei hinsicht der erde sehr ähnlich und auch deswegen halten viele
außerirdisches leben dort für äußerst wahrscheinlich die nasa plant bis zum jahr
2025 eine art rhone die dragon fly zum titan zu starten um nach möglichen
Landeplätzen auf dem saturnmond ausschau zu halten jetzt haben amerikanische wissenschaftlerin
wissenschaftler eine weitere faszinierende erkenntnisse über den titanen gewonnen wie die chancen also für
außerirdisches leben auf dem titan stehen ihr habt euch genau dieses video in der whatsapp
Community von pixum science fiction gewünscht also bitteschön hier ist es herzlich willkommen
Der titan ist der größte der saturnmonde und er gilt als der erdähnlichste himmelskörper, im sonnensystem
Er besitzt eine atmosphäre einen wahren kern sehen regen und wolken sowie canons sein oberfläche ist so groß wie die
kontinente afrika europa und asien zusammen viele infos zu titan haben wir durch die esa-sonde ruhigen bekommen die von der raumsonde cassini
Dorthin gebracht wurde auf den bildern waren unter anderem erdähnliche berger aus eis zu sehen schon länger ist also klar dass die
oberfläche des saturnmonds
zu großen teilen mit flüssigkeit bedeckt ist wieder eine ähnlichkeit zur erde doch in den gewässern
Des zitates ist kein wasser zu finden sondern kalte kohlenwasserstoffe konkret handelt es sich. Um eins das aus
Gefrorenen etan und metern besteht jetzt hat ein team der amerikanischen cornell university noch mehr erstaunliche fakten
zu titan gewinnen können und zwar aufgrund der auswertung der letzten
Daten die die mittlerweile verglühte cassini raumsonde gesammelt hatte und das ergebnis das lässt wirklich aufhorchen
Die drei großen mehrere, im fachjargon jahre genannt gleichen sich einander aus heißt also sie haben einen gemeinsamen
meeresspiegel vergleichbar mit den ozean der erde dazu einer der beteiligten forscher alexander hess die flüssigkeit pegel der drei polaren mare
unterscheiden sich nicht mehr als acht meter voneinander das spricht dafür dass diese sehen miteinander verbunden sind auf unserer erde sorgt ein
Kompliziertes system aus flüssen dazu dass der meeresspiegel aus beglichen ist
Wie dieser ausgleich auf dem titan geschieht ist noch nicht geklärt unterirdische verbindung also
schluchten oder kanäle könnten dafür verantwortlich seien eine entdeckung des amerikanischen forschungsteams spricht dafür
dass der großteil der titanen flüssigkeit unterhalb seiner oberfläche fließt nur
diejenigen vertiefungen die oberhalb des pegels der gefüllten nachbar seen liegen sind nicht, mit flüssigkeit gefüllt da zuerst
Legen sie tiefer würden auch sie sich fühlen das spricht dafür dass es unter der oberfläche eine verbindung gibt und dass in der tiefe
flüssige kohlenwasserstoffe
zirkulieren und auch die seen des titels bleiben weiter rätselhaft denn sowohl die gefüllten als auch die
trockenen mulden weisen extrem steile ufer auf teilweise ragen die uferkante bis zu 200 meter in die tiefe
forschungsteams weltweit können sich zudem nicht erklären warum die seen von teilweise hunderte meter hohen hülsten umgeben sind wie lassen sich diese
seltsamen sehen form geologisch erklären eine vermutung ist dass bestimmte
einsturz phänomene diese formationen produzierten auf der erde wird das cars genannt gemeint sind dabei kalkstein
informationen bei denen wasser teile des gesteins löst und so
Höhlensysteme formt fest steht jedenfalls
nicht all diese neuen faszinierenden erkenntnisse lassen sich mit gängigen
Geologischen prozessen erklären doch je mehr wir über den saturnmond erfahren
umso wahrscheinlicher wird es dass wir dort demnächst leben finden können oder aber selbst umsiedeln können schon
2015 vermutete ein forschungsteam dass mikroben auf dem titan leben die sich von dem gas
acetylen ernähren und methan ausscheiden und die nasa ist nicht allein bei ihrem plan den titan in zukunft auch für den menschen bewohnbar
zu machen die wissenschaftlerin amanda hendrix
aus arizona hat ein ganzes buch darüber geschrieben warum der titan eine bessere option für eine
Langfristige menschliche siedlung ist als der mars unter anderem konzentriert sie sich dabei auf die kosmische strahlung vor der der
titanen durch seine dichte atmosphäre
einen natürlichen schutz
Bietet wenn er als erstes neues zum thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor
allen an
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von klicks zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
Der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
raumsonde cassini schafft durch flug zwischen saturn und seinen ringen ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran